So, what did you have to do at your internship? What.
Was that like? So at first they, I have a, some, uh, one,
not two weeks of, uh, uh, experience of how to do a walk,
how a character's do a rotation of the head. Uh, so exercise,
it would be exercise on paper. Okay. And, uh, so I plus,
Oh, I know that, um, that I, like I said,
I know the Western, the business, I didn't know,
Japanese way, we to, uh, um, less frame, uh,
we did just as some key and after you do the in-betweens, but, uh,
I had to keep hoses and I have to clean up these key poses and do the,
in between strangers.
So the, the in-between frames. So I assume as they say, right, like alienated,
right. Do you want, do you wanna explain it,
explain key frames and you've been in between.
This is one, yeah. Two, right. Four. I pinch one,
two, but for, uh,
do I need some in-betweens to read maybe this DKI pose,
uh, in betweens, right. In betweens keyboards.
And those are the in-betweens are normally not as polished as the.
Uh, the soldier in between. It's a,
you have to take it the two key keepers and to layer them.
And do you do the in-betweens then? Like that? Oh, okay.
Yeah, basically like the plugin in,
after effects that people put over the animate to make it 60 FPS,
but someone's actually doing that themselves. Right.
That's why I can describe it.
In Japan. We are, uh, 24 FPS, right?
Yeah. And then that's the in-between frames and only given to like, interns.
Yeah. So at first I, you know, when you start or you start has a dual Garmin,
you said, so the guy is moving it's mean moving pictures,
but, uh, it's been, uh, in between in Japan.
And so I had done this for two weeks and after just two weeks,
so they put me on a productions. Oh, wow. And it was
wow. Uh, two weeks of exercise and the last, uh, uh,
two months and half, it was, uh, on the production of Lupin, the song.
I thought he'd be getting coffee or something for two weeks and working on
lupine.
So I was,
it was a two to two weeks of exertion after two months and half on Lupin. Uh,
it was, uh, uh, TV special. So a TV show and, uh,
yes, it was my first experience.
And so I met a lot of famous animators,
a lot of veterans and the staff was very nice to me.
It was [inaudible] uh, I just
[inaudible] and yeah, the stuff was very nice. There were, there was wondering,
Oh, why, why do you know?
No in yea I to go, boy, I want to,
I want to walk in Japan.
Yeah. Do you want, do you want to be an animator for animate, man?
I feel bad for our intern now. Like I'm, I'm sorry, Ashley,
like hearing the story, you know.
So, and I had a Metta senpai, a French senpai who,
my name, uh, Krista [inaudible] and a French.
[Inaudible].
That, uh, take a time and a walk very late.
And peep when you walk very right. Less than two meters,
but the bus is not here. And so anyway says are more, um,
uh, they are more free to speak to you.
[Inaudible].
Oh, you work harder than very nice, uh, late. Uh, what are you doing?
I feel like that must be your bonding experience. Right?
Cause you're staying up late.
Yeah, exactly. Uh, when most of my good
friends was because, uh, uh, yes, we walk through reacted,
uh, uh, eight o'clock of the morning because we work hard. We didn't slept.
And your brother.
[Inaudible]
, so you literally just sent an email to a company and then you flew to Japan
and wow. loop literally within a month. So what timeframe
was it from you sending that email to the company, to you being in Japan?
Yeah. Uh, so, uh, I sent a mail in January,
they said, okay. And so I went in June.
Six, six.
But, uh, yes, but
I was pretty Rocky because the director said yes,
and now the director is not no more walking at telecom animation.
He's now in Thai. Uh, and yeah, so it was cool.
And so this was my first experience in the Japanese animation industry.
What was it? 10 years ago? And so I went to another,
an emission school and to descend emissions, Coro. I had to, uh,
have a dedication to do a summer school at a gobbler.
Uh [inaudible] it's a French famous, cool animation. And I have met, um,
uh, [inaudible], uh,
he's very famous. So because he's maybe the, the pop of the French and the
meters in Japan. And also because he's very famous, uh,  he redrew his kids, uh,
drawings. Oh, wow.
Oh, that sounds familiar. Sounds very familiar.
That sounds like you blew up on the radio or something, right?
Yeah.
So he kids drew and he picked a picture of [inaudible]
has a professor.
Yeah, that sounds, that sounds very familiar. Yeah.
I met him at, um, at this a summer and, uh, I,
he gave me a, a Beto with him and he gave me uh he's um,
uh, he's cards, business cards, and connection is very important.
Like I said, uh, this summer. Cool. I could do it because I'm infected,
you're jerked off to recommend mission school was doing a summer school. I,
the gallbladder, but he needed as translator. Oh,
call me okay. In France as you can help me. Right. Right.
And that's why the first, the first way to find a contact is very difficult.
When you have one he can introduce to.
To someone else door opens, but that's what it is with live with.
Like the enemy industry. Is that like, it's only so big. Yeah. So once you know,
one person, yeah. It's just the hard part is getting in,
but everyone I've met who is working in the anime industry,
especially if they're a foreigner,
they've just had like that one lucky pool of light. Yeah. Just,
just like the one lucky in, and once they brought that here.
As you animators, it's the first time it's a difficult to entry,
but after is to stay here. So let me explain, uh, later, but, uh,
so yeah,
so I sent a mailer to Tamara Roma and tomorrow man was walking at this time at a
satellite. Okay. Swords are very famous, uh,
for the series Macross and.
Innovation studio, I assume. Yeah. They,
the log Corizon as well as season one of the seasons SU.
Yeah.
And so, uh,
I could manage to a four months internship, et cetera. Right. Wow. And,
but it was very different con uh,
it was a bit more quarter, a bit more rush.
Oh, hurry up, hurry up. Uh, and, uh, take them,
the animators were coming at 10 and leaving at night, or like at 10 or so,
but are at satellite.
Everybody was coming in the afternoon to a four and was walking
at a 6:00 AM.
Oh God, Jesus. A lot more like hardcore.